فليس هناك من المؤن الكثير اصبح التقشف
منادى اسر في العاصمه الخرطوم بقضايا ايام
يصعب فيها الحصول على الزاد في ظل
الاقتتال الدائر بين الجيش وقوات الدعم
السريع منذ نحو اسبوع
في ابسط متطلبات الحياه
فعلينا فتره طبعا بنعاني معاناه كبيره جدا
جدا في ابسط الحاجات اليوميه الكنا احنا
بنعيشها وبنحتاجه هموم تدعى الدحيز الماكل
والمشربي للتعامل مع خوف الاطفال ودعرهم
احنا بقينا ما بدنا نوم مطمئنين ما اطفالي
كل ثواني بيسالوني 100 سؤال ما عارفين
ذاته الحاصل شنو ما قادره اجاوب لهم
بالذات الصغير يعني بيسمع الاصوات بتاع
الدرب النار والرصاص بيسالني يا ماما انا
ما بكون عارفه اجاوب ليه
يتذكر ابنه ساره الكبير جيدا صوت الرصاص
اثناء اختبار في مدرستي عزيز بدد امنياته
في قضاء عيد يلم الشمل وانا كنت اخذت مخطط
طويل للعيد لكن
الحرب بدل
انا
البيت يلف الظلام
تعطلت في دبيها وعيد على الابواب تستعد له
الاسر بتخزين مجهول لكن في النهايه
على الاسبوع فربنا سبحان الله يعني ان شاء
الله بتفرج بتفرج باذن الله بتفرج واذا
فرج تتطلع الاسر اليه بهدوء الطرفين الى
الحوار وايقاف الاقتتال انا بدعو الله انه
يعني الحرب
المسؤولين
والمدنيين والعسكريين كلهم انه يناقشنو
بايغاف هذا الحرب وبعد كده نقعد في طاوله
واحده نشوف يعني بيحصل شنو
خارج المنازل تبقى الحياه مشلوله لاسيما
في الطرق الرئيسيه القريبه من مناطق
الاشتباكات وسط العاصمه
في داخل الاحياء يجد الناس متنفس لقضاء
حوائجهم ووقتا لتبديد الهم وصناعه امال
العوده الى ما قبل مربع الحرب